with sweeping new measures in america's
three most heavily populated cities to
try and slow the coronavirus
new york city is now setting up
coronavirus checkpoints for people
entering from hot spots
chicago says all its public schools will
use remote learning at the start of the
new school year
and los angeles announced a crackdown on
house parties and threatened to cut off
water and power we start with our lead
national correspondent david begna who's
in miami david first tell us about this
enforcement effort
in l.a jeff if the city of los angeles
now gets a report and they can confirm
that there is a large gathering of
people at a private property they are
going to ask the utility service in los
angeles
to cut water and power to that property
within 48 hours
now this drastic decision follows a
party earlier in the week near beverly
hills
where the police could clearly see and
cameras showed people gathering together
at a large party here in the south where
we are the virus is spreading
out of control and we want to zero in
this morning on the state of mississippi
which is
leading the nation in a way that they
don't want to cases per capita are the
highest in mississippi
than anywhere else and doctors are
alarmed
this was the scene inside of the icu at
the university of mississippi medical
center in jackson yesterday
it is mississippi's largest and most
specialized hospital
it is the only one that can offer the
complex medical procedures
that most critically ill patients need
and it is completely
full within our walls we have 14
patients that need an icu bed
and there is not one available that is
dr luanne woodward
she is the dean of the school of
medicine at the university of
mississippi
she says with cases on the rise and
nearly 25
of the cases coming back positive the
current crisis in mississippi
may go on for months i'm hoping the tide
is turning
but i think there has been a very deep
disconnect between many people in
mississippi
and the understanding of what we're
seeing
[Music]
in neighboring louisiana there was a
prayer service held at turling's
catholic high school in lafayette
for 19 year old david lemare we spoke to
his father mark
how many of your children were infected
by the virus
uh four hour five were you and your wife
infected
yes david and his younger brother jacob
were both hospitalized with coronavirus
and put in the same icu at one point the
brothers even shared the same room
that is where david took this picture of
jacob looking back at his brother
with clear concern in his eyes why did
they bring him in the room together at
one point
um because david's condition had uh
deteriorated and uh they're very close
and they thought that would be a good
good for for both of them
david was airlifted to new orleans for
more complex medical treatments
mark went with him seen here by david's
side holding his hand
as machines oxygenated david's blood to
give his lungs a rest
but the virus had ravaged this 19 year
old's lungs beyond repair
david died on july 31st after more than
one month
in the hospital my son david was a very
very vibrant
very alive college students i've learned
a lot about my son
about how compassionate he was and uh
how deep his faith was this loss has
just been overwhelming
obviously for our family
i told mark that one of david's high
school teachers told me that david is
remembered by his high school
as being one of the nicest kids on
campus what a beautiful thing to be
remembered by
listen i want you to know that david was
treated with every drug available
rem deserve convalescent plasma steroids
they gave him everything they could
vlad david had asthma as a child but
hadn't been treated with medication
since the fifth grade
he ran cross country in high school and
was running several miles a day
the week before he was infected with the
virus
david you're reporting once again
driving home the fact that no one is
safe
from the coronavirus and we should all
take precautions as you've reported
wear a mask thank you david begneau for
us we appreciate